12 years ago today I asked somebody on
my team to run to Best Buy pick up a
little Canon camera set it up I picked
three bottles of wine and put them on a
table I filmed it first time I've ever
filmed anything with the purpose of
anybody seeing it hello everyone and
welcome to the first episode of Wine
Library TV I am Gary Vaynerchuk director
of operations here at Wine Library and
it started the process of where we are
here today twelve years later
when I hear people lacking patience or
wanting it so fast or not understanding
the marathon I've basically been
producing content for the internet for
the last 12 years and and I really wish
so many of you could understand how
quick that's gone and how much longer I
have to go but most of all realize how
much didn't happen in those first
several years
[Music]
how much I needed to persevere and build
an audience how much engaging and
replying to people along the way and
building relationships and hugging and
kissing babies and grinding and
believing and and most of all what's so
interesting is I sit here right now
outside this airport knowing that 65% of
you didn't know who I was 24 months ago
15 months ago that my current place of
attention is a current phenomenon
it's a 1516 month phenomenon that things
kind of took a little bit of a hockey
stick moment which means 10 and a half
years ten half years of grinding and
putting out stuff and wanting to share
my thoughts on wine on business on
entrepreneurship
day in and day out day in and day out
Wow I worked all the time building
businesses while this wasn't even my
full-time thing I have so much empathy
that you want it I'm so much everything
I want for you to get yours but Jesus
this doesn't happen overnight it just
does it
[Music]
[Music]
you